THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> INNOCENT CIVILIANS SUFFERING
AS RUSSIA'S UNPROVOKED INVASION
OF UKRAINE ENTERS A NEW PHASE.
AFTER FAILING TO QUICKLY CAP
SLUR CITIES LIKE KYIV, PUTIN
APPEARS TO BE SHIFTING FOCUS TO
INFLICT AS MUCH DAMAGE TO THE
COUNTRY AS POSSIBLE.
THE CITY OF MARIUPOL REFUSING
RUSSIA'S DEMAND TO SURRENDER,
EVEN AFTER ENDURING WEEKS OF
DEVASTATING AIR STRIKES.
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT ZELENSKY
CONTINUES CALL FOR PEACE, BUT
SAYS HIS COUNTRY WON'T GIVE ANY
LAND TO RUSSIA.
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO USE ANY
FORMAT, ANY CHANCE THAT YOU HAVE
POSSIBILITY OF NEGOTIATING,
POSSIBILITY OF TALKING TO PUTIN.
BUT IF THESE ATTEMPTS FAIL, THAT
WOULD MEAN THAT THIS IS A THIRD
WORLD WAR.
>> THIS COMES AS PRESIDENT BIDEN
PREPARES TO HEAD TO EUROPE WHERE
HE'LL ATTEND A MAJOR NATO IN
BRUSSELS AS WELL AS THE
PRESIDENT IN WARSAW.
>> AIR RAID SIRENS CONTINUE TO
GO OFF.
DESPITE THOSE WARNINGS, PEOPLE
IN THE CITY ARE VERY MUCH TRYING
TO GET ON WITH THEIR DAILY LIVES
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
BUT THEY DO REALIZE THAT AT ANY
MOMENT THINGS COULD CHANGE AND
THEY ARE WATCHING VERY CLOSELY
WHAT'S HAPPENING JUST OUTSIDE OF
THIS CITY CENTER, ESPECIALLY TO
THE EAST AND TO THE SOUTH AND
COASTAL TOWNS LIKE MARIUPOL,
WHERE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW ARE TRAPPED AND
TRYING TO GET OUT OF HARM'S WAY
AFTER RUSSIA ISSUED THAT
ULTIMATUM FOR THE CITY TO LAY
DOWN THE ARMS.
THE MAYOR REJECTED THE OFFER TO
SURRENDER WITHOUT HESITATION.
OFFICIALS SAY WEEKS OF HEAVY
SHELLING AND BOMBARDMENTS THEY
ESTIMATE UPWARDS OF 2,300 PEOPLE
HAVE DIED IN THE CITY.
RESIDENTS WHO SURVIVED THE
ATTACK SAY BATTLES ARE TAKING
PLACE ON NEARLY EVERY STREET.
>> THERE IS NO MARIUPOL ANYMORE.
THEY BOMBED EVERYTHING.
IT'S ALL THIS MATERNITY HOSPITAL
AND ART SCHOOL -- ALL OF THIS IS
VERY CATCHY FOR THE USE OF THE
NEW YEAR.
BUT BOMBED EVERYTHING.
WE DON'T HAVE MARIUPOL ANYMORE.
WE HAVE TO BUILD THIS CITY FROM
SCRATCH.
>> IN KYIV CREWS ARE SIFTING
THROUGH WHAT'S LEFT OF A
SHOPPING CENTER AFTER IT WAS
BLOWN UP LAST NIGHT.
UKRAINE ESTIMATES AS MANY AS
EIGHT WERE KILLED AFTER A
RUSSIAN-FIRED ROCKET BLASTED
THROUGH THE MALL IN THAT CITY.
THE EXPLOSION CHARRED CARS AND
SENT SHRAPNEL INTO HOMES AND
BUSINESSES.
RUSSIA CLAIMS THAT THEY ONLY
TARGETED THE SHOPPING CENTER
BECAUSE IT WAS HOUSING UKRAINIAN
MISSILES AND ROCKETS, BUT THAT
CLAIM HAS NOT BEEN INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRMED BY ANYONE.
ONE MOTHER WHO SPOKE JUST TODAY
ABOUT THAT INCIDENT SAID HER
DAUGHTER WAS WORKING IN THAT
VERY SHOPPING CENTER AND YOU CAN
JUST IMAGINE SOME OF THE
THOUGHTS JUST THINKING IF THAT
ATTACK HAD HAPPENED JUST A DAY
BEFORE.
>> THANKS SO MUCH.
STAY SAFE.
DANA, I'M GOING TO START WITH
YOU.
WE'RE IN THE FOURTH WEEK OF THIS
AND EVERY DAY WE HEAR ABOUT MORE
AND MORE ATTACKS ON CIVILIANS,
CIVILIAN PROTESTERS BEING SHOT
AND KILLED.
WE HEAR MORE AND MORE ABOUT
LITERALLY WAR CRIMES HAPPENING.
WHEN ZELENSKY TALKS ABOUT THE
BEGINNING OF THE THIRD WORLD
WAR, IS HE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE POSSIBLY?
>> WELL, THAT PHRASE HAS BEEN
USED SINCE THE FIRST DAY OF THIS
INVASION BY SOME BECAUSE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
IS TRYING TO DO AND OTHER NATO
COUNTRIES IS TO FIGURE OUT HOW
DO YOU PROVIDE UKRAINIANS ENOUGH
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES WITHOUT,
AGAIN -- I DISAGREE WITH HOW WE
ARE DESCRIBING HOW PUTIN IS
PROVOKED, BECAUSE HE'S PROVOKED
BY EVERYTHING.
BUT TO PROVOKE HIM INTO A
NUCLEAR WAR.
NOBODY WANTS THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT PUTIN WANTS,
BUT I IMAGINE HE DOESN'T WANT
THAT.
I THINK THIS TRIP THAT BIDEN IS
GOING TO TAKE THIS WEEK IS
IMPORTANT.
I THINK IT'S GOOD THAT HE'S
GOING.
I THINK IT'S TIME FOR SOME MORE
FRONT-SEAT DIPLOMACY.
HE SENT KAMALA HARRIS.
THAT DID NOT NECESSARILY MOVE
THE NEEDLE.
NOW HE HAS TO GO.
I THINK IT'S BETTER TO BE
SITTING IN A ROOM FACE TO FACE
WITH OTHER NATO LEADERS RATHER
THAN ON ZOOM.
THEY HAVE A TERRIBLE DILEMMA IN
THIS SITUATION.
WE'RE GIVING THE UKRAINIANS
ENOUGH TO KEEP -- THEY ARE DOING
PRETTY WELL DEFENDING
THEMSELVES.
IT COULD BE THAT ZELENSKY THINKS
HE CAN KEEP THE CAPITAL CITY OF
KYIV, BUT OUTSIDE OF KYIV, IF
YOU DON'T GIVE THEM ENOUGH TO
WIN QUICKLY, THEN YOU'RE GOING
TO LOSE SLOWLY.
IF THAT HAPPENS, THEN YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE THE DEATH TOLL OF
CIVILIANS INCREASE MUCH MORE.
>> YOU KNOW, JOEY, I'LL GO TO
YOU ON THAT.
IT APPEARS WE'RE AT A STALEMATE
RIGHT NOW, THAT THERE WERE --
THERE WAS A DEADLINE THAT WAS
GIVEN TO ZELENSKY AT 10:00 P.M.
OUR TIME LAST NIGHT TO SURRENDER
AND HE HASN'T GOTTEN MARIUPOL --
PUTIN HASN'T GOTTEN KYIV.
HE'S TRYING TO DESTROY AND CRUSH
THE SPIRITS OF THE UKRAINIANS.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE AT A STALEMATE,
IT'S A VERY DANGEROUS TIME, IS
IT NOT?
AND WHAT DOES PUTIN DO NOW?
>> I THINK WHEN ZELENSKY SAYS
THEN IT WILL BE WORLD WAR III, I
THINK WHAT HE'S SAYING, IN MY
OPINION, IF WE CONTINUE TO HOLD
HIM OFF, HE'S GOING TO
EVENTUALLY -- PUTIN IS GOING TO
EVENTUALLY USE CHEMICAL WEAPONS,
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THE WEST SAID WHEN THAT HAPPENS,
THEY ARE INVOLVED.
I THINK ZELENSKY IS SAYING IS
YOU ALL UNDERESTIMATED US, WE'RE
ABLE TO STAY IN THIS FIGHT
BECAUSE OF THE WEAPONS YOU'RE
GIVING US.
IF WE DON'T WIN DECISIVELY,
THAT'S WHAT'S NEXT.
THAT MIGHT BE TRUE.
WE TRY TO REPORT ON THIS EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
YOU CAN'T REPORT ON THIS ONE DAY
TO THE OTHER.
WE SAY THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN
MARIUPOL.
BUT MARIUPOL IS A WASTELAND OF
WAR.
SO DOES IT MATTER IF THEY ARE
SITTING IN THE CITY CENTER OR
NOT?
THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM HERE.
JUST LIKE WHAT DANA WAS SAYING,
TO WRAP THIS UP, IF THE END
RESULT IS WE'RE THREE MONTHS OF
WAR AND 30,000 PEOPLE DEAD AND
RUSSIA STANDING IN THE CENTER OF
KYIV, WHEN YOU LOOK BACK, WHAT
DO YOU SAY?
WHAT WAS THE PURPOSE OF THIS
WAR?
WHAT WAS GAINED FROM IT?
WHAT WAS GAINED FROM THE 30,000
DEATHS?
IT MAY BE THE NEXT 30 YEARS OF
INSURGENCY.
>> YOU KNOW, GREG, WITH RESPECT
TO THAT, LET'S ASSUME THAT HE
JUST -- SCORCHED EARTH FROM THIS
POINT ON.
HE WILL NEVER DEFEAT THE
UKRAINIANS' SPIRIT AND THE
RUSSIANS DON'T APPEAR TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY OCCUPY.
WHAT DO THE RUSSIANS DO AT THAT
POINT?
>> YOU KNOW, YOUR FANTASY IS
THAT THEY TAKE CARE OF THE
PROBLEM THEMSELVES.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN BECAUSE PUTIN IS SO
FAR REMOVED.
IT'S WEIRD HE'S ESSENTIALLY
DESTROYING THE VERY THING THAT
HE CLAIMS THAT HE CHERISHES,
WHICH IS UKRAINE.
IT'S LIKE A REALLY BITTER
ACRIMONIOUS BREAKUP WHERE THE
CREEP GOES, WELL, IF I CAN'T
HAVE YOU, NO ONE WELL.
>> THEN IT GETS REAL BAD.
>> IT IS THE OPPOSITE OF DAMAGE
CONTROL, WHAT HE'S DOING.
I'M PESSIMISTIC ABOUT BIDEN JUST
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
HE'S IN ANY PARTICULAR RUSH TO
FIX THIS.
WE KNOW THAT -- WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT HOW MANY EXAMPLES THERE
ARE OF PLACES WHERE WE HAVE
HELPED AND IT DIDN'T HELP.
I'M BEGINNING TO FEEL THAT THE
LONGER WE DO THIS, THE LONGER IT
GOES ON AND THE LONGER THAT IT
GOES ON, THE MORE PEOPLE DIE.
IT'S REALLY WEIRD.
THIS IS THE LONGEST FOG OF WAR I
HAVE SEEN.
BOTH SIDES ARE CALLING EACH
OTHER NAZIS.
RUSSIA WAS FIRST WHEN THEY DID
THAT.
WE NEED SOME KIND OF CREATIVE
THINKING AND I GO BACK TO THE
ONLY EXAMPLE THAT I CAN THINK
OF, YOU KNOW, WHEN TRUMP WENT TO
NORTH KOREA, IT WAS LIKE, LET'S
SEE WHAT HAPPENS, LET'S SHAKE
THE BOX, SEE WHAT HAPPENS, WE
CAN PROMISE SOMETHING.
AT LEAST IT WAS INNOVATIVE AND
IT INTRODUCED ANOTHER VARIABLE
INTO A SITUATION WHERE WE
ALREADY KNEW THE VARIABLES THERE
WERE NOT WORKING.
NOW WE'RE FOUR WEEKS IN AND
WE'RE KIND OF IN THE SAME PLACE
WE WERE BEFORE.
>> THE REASON WHY PUTIN WAS ABLE
TO SELL THIS TO BEGIN WITH IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN -- I'M NOT
TAKING A POSITION BECAUSE I
WOULD HAVE TO READ A BUNCH OF
BOOKS TO GET THERE.
WHEN AMERICANS SIT THERE AND SAY
IT WAS REAL EASY FOR CHARLIE
WILSON'S WAR, THAT DIDN'T BOTHER
US UNTIL WE'RE IN A WAR FOR 20
YEARS.
I GET AGGRAVATED FOR I SAT IN
FRONT OF A TELEVISION, AMERICANS
PLEASE ASK QUESTIONS BEFORE WE
GET INTO ANOTHER WAR.
IF YOU DO THAT NOW, YOU'RE IN
PUTIN'S POCKET, RIGHT?
>> EXACTLY.
>> COME ON.
THERE HAS TO BE OPPORTUNITY FOR
AMERICANS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE'RE GETTING INTO AND AT ANY
POINT, NO MATTER HOW RIGHTEOUS
THE CAUSE.
>> JESSICA, THE WHOLE IDEA IF
WE'RE FIGHTING TO THIS POINT
WHERE WE'RE AT A STALEMATE, IT'S
ABOUT DIPLOMACY ISN'T IT?
>> A LOT OF IT IS.
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT JOHN
SAID WE'RE DOING THINGS WE'RE
NOT TELLING YOU ABOUT, WHICH IS
WHAT EVERYONE IS ASKING FOR.
YOU'RE THE MOST POWERFUL
GOVERNMENT IN THE WORLD WITH THE
MOST WEAPONS THAT IS DOING MORE
THAN THEY ARE TELLING US.
THAT IS A GAME CHANGER BECAUSE
ONE CONSISTENT THING THAT I HAVE
NOTICED FROM EVERYONE I HAVE
TALKED ABOUT, EVERYONE IS ON THE
SAME SIDE, WHETHER REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT, IS WE WANT TO KNOW
WHAT ARE YOU DOING FOR THEM,
THESE PEOPLE ARE MAKING SUCH
PERSONAL APPEALS, ZELENSKY HAS
JUST -- THE VIDEOS HE'S PUTTING
OUT, EMOTIONAL.
HE'S TAKING US ON A TOUR OF
UKRAINE THAT MAKES IT PALPABLE
FOR THE AVERAGE PERSON SITTING
AT THEIR HOME IN KENTUCKY.
JOHN KIRBY SAID, WE'RE NOT GOING
TO TELL YOU WHAT'S ON THE
GROUND, BUT WE'RE DOING MORE
THAN YOU THINK THAT WE'RE DOING.
>> CAN I ADD ONE THING, JUDGE?
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO DO WITH
WEAPONS, BUT IT COULD BE
SOMETHING THAT COULD HELP THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE AND NOT HELP
PUTIN.
COULD YOU FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
HAVE A CREATIVE BANKING SYSTEM
THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE IN RUSSIA
THAT CAN'T LEAVE RUSSIA OR THE
ONES WHO LEFT RUSSIA ALREADY,
FIND A WAY FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO BE PART OF OUR BANKING SYSTEM
OR INTERNATIONAL BANKING SYSTEM
BUT SEPARATE OUT PEOPLE LIKE
PUTIN AND OLIGARCHS AND THE
MILITARY -- A CREATIVE WAY TO DO
IT WITHOUT WEAPONS?
>> SMART -- IT'S TOO
INTELLIGENT.
>> NOT ONLY THAT.
YOU DRAW A DISTINCTION.
THAT IS BETWEEN PUTIN AND THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE.
AND WE'VE GOT T